public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
public sénat en parts
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
président du modem conseiller politique
d' emmanuel macron françois bayrou est
l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité pour
yahoo et maire de pau bien sûr je
n'oublie pas votre mandat électoral
françois bayrou merci d'être avec nous
ce soir
alors que la campagne du second tour est
désormais évidemment bien engagé vous
répondrai au cours de cette émission à
trois grandes questions que viendront
vous posez jean-francis pécresse de
radio classique et des échos jérémy
marot de la fp et mickaël szames s de
public sénat première question comment
mobiliser face au front national
deuxième question quelle majorité demain
pour gouverner alors qu'au ps et chez
les républicains
certains sont prêts à vous rejoindre
enfin troisième question à quoi
ressembleront les premiers mois de la
présidence et ponctuelle des manuels
macron mais tout de suite une toute
première question d'actualité
[Musique]
est-ce que emmanuel macron a commis une
erreur de jeunesse j'ai envie de dire de
novices en donnant l'impression dimanche
soir de fêter déjà sa victoire dans ce
contexte où l'on voit le front national
très puissant et un pays fracturée alors
j'entends cette polémique ou ce semblant
de polémique
il est allé boire un pot avec son équipe
et mangé un morceau dans une brasserie
absolument classique parisienne et donc
il n'y a pas la moindre ombre de deux de
fêter quoi quelques victoires que ce
soit ils ont fait ensemble pris un pot à
la fin du premier tour et deux mois et
de mois de un combat difficile donc le
soleil ali ben ali était envoyé ce
qu'ils étaient influencés par les
commentaires que je me fais de fleury
sur il a réalisé le hold up du siècle
l'argent le jeu ne bloque pas la moelle
à premiers mois qui lui parle assez
souvent je pense qu'il a tout à fait
la sensation de la gravité de la
situation et du poids de la tâche qui va
être la sienne
et c'est cela qui est pour moi
l'essentiel après quand on quand on
arrive en tête d'une élection alors que
présidentielle alors que c'est la
première fois qu'en se présentent aux
suffrages
bien entendu il ya le sentiment qu'on a
réalisé quelque chose qui était pour le
moins inattendu c'est incontestable et
donc on a l'habitude de dire qu'il faut
trente ans pour être devenir président
de la république lui en moins de 12 mois
il a plus qu'une marche à gravir pour
entrer à l'elysée et puis il a fait
alors exploser le système c'est à dire
ce que vous vous attendez depuis 15 ans
dans la rue on vient ggd et je l'aide
dans cette tâche qui était de salubrité
nationale et donc cette question est
importante elle est posée comme ça de
manière anecdotique comme si c'était un
contour d'une histoire qu'on raconte
mais c'est pas ça du tout la question la
question ce qu'il ya des moments où les
pays ont besoin d'un bol d'air frais et
un moment où on est tellement au bout de
deux de la lassitude de de l'
exaspération à l'égard de blocage de
système qui marche plus qu' il ya des
moments où les pays se tourne vers une
vision nouvelle vers un regard nouveau
une recomposition et pas seulement vers
est un homme n'ouvre une personnalité un
homme nouvel e jeune et qui en est fait
à
est sortie du cadre qu'on voulait lui
tracé est en tout cas pour moi qui
attend ce moment depuis tellement
longtemps
je considère que c'est un moment clé de
l'histoire quand est ce que vraiment
vous avez fait la fête dimanche soir
même si vous n'étiez pas à la rotonde je
n'étais pas là haut tombe vous historia
les hommes j'étais invité mais je moi je
pense que les moments de joie les plus
importants sont les plus retenus alors
c'est un conseil qui portera peut-être
auprès d' emmanuel macron justement
avant de dérouler le fil de cette
émission était trois questions s'il y
avait un conseil stratégique que vous
pourriez nous faire dont vous pourriez
nous faire genève et que vous donnez je
l'avais sonné et que vous vous apprêtez
à donner elles que soit demandée
marseille que je donne je puis vous
assurer que je ne les donne pas sur les
plateaux de télévision
oui je suis pas le jeu ne vit pas ce
moment comme un moment de me voulons
s'exprime à la première personne je vis
ce moment comme un moment où des équipes
se forment qui vont avoir la lourde
responsabilité de sortir notre pays de
l'impasse dans laquelle il se trouve
depuis combien 15 ans 20 ans 15 ans et
20 ans qu'on a qu'on vit l'impuissance
publique 15 ans 20 ans que
l'exaspération monte et il va appartenir
à cette équipe nouvelle 2e d'extraire le
l'énergie du pays pour qu'ils deviennent
rayonnait obtenir des résultats et c'est
un sacré défi pour effet sacré défi
celui celle qui entrera à l'elysée tout
de suite la première question posée
désormais par jean francis pécresse le
directeur de la rédaction de radio
classique
bon ça c'est voir michel bonsoir
françois bayrou elle reçoit visière on
voit marine le pen qui tente de
mobiliser contre emmanuel macron comment
comptez vous vous y prendre pour
mobilisez-vous contre marine le pen
il n'y a rien de plus simple il suffit
de dire la vérité et vous vous
connaissez la vérité je veux dire que
professionnellement vous êtes
spécialiste économique
vous savez une chose c'est que si on
suivait et je parle pas de vos opinions
là on est en dehors des opinions
si on suivait les directions que madame
le pen propose on aurait le malheur pour
la france est en france pour les plus
faibles de la france
on aurait le malheur parce que si on
sortait de l'euro pour revenir au franc
la monnaie se casserait la figure et que
donc les retraites par exemple ne
vaudrait plus le montant du chèque le
pouvoir d'achat s'effondrerait on aurait
d'incroyables difficultés budgétaires
par exemple tous ceux qui veulent
emprunter pour construire une maison
pour acheter une voiture pour de
l'électroménager il verrait les taux
d'intérêts explosé et ceci est si
vérifier au travers du monde chaque fois
qu'on a essayé ça que d'une certaine
manière il nous revient à tous
comme citoyen comme spécialiste pour
vous comme citoyen pour moi de dire la
vérité au pays et cette vérité sera
mobilisatrice vous voyez que je jeu par
des propositions sans même évoquer les
arrière pensées qui sont des
arrière-pensées extrêmement dangereuse
de 10
vision des français sur les sujets les
plus explosifs qu'on peut trouver qui
tous à l'origine de doux viens tu quelle
est ta religion que qui est ennemie avec
qui tout cela comme vous savez j'ai
toute ma vie voulu réconcilier les
français dépassé les frontières et les
antagonismes persuadé ce peuple qui l'a
beaucoup plus en commun pour se
rassembler qu'il n'a pour se diviser et
pour moi en tout cas c'est un combat de
deux de chaque seconde combat intérieur
et combat dans le débat public question
mais marine le pen elle est laissée
depuis hier de convaincre les français
que celui qui va les appauvrir sait pas
elle mais c'est emmanuel macron et deux
au fond montrer aux atouts l'électorat
que le projet dangereux économiquement
c'est pas son projet c'est le projet d'
emmanuel macron messas comme vous savez
c c'est de l'argumentaire politiciens la
question est que mais est-ce que cela
fera porter quand même auprès de ces
français qui sont réfractaires qu'elle a
ses arguments économiques que vous
développez que développe 25 prix nobel
de l'économie que développe ceux qui
font marcher l'économie c'est à dire
tous les patrons mais qui se heurte
quand même à une sorte de mur de
l'incompréhension et 40% des français
usés mois s'il y avait lieu les votes de
marine le pen
je ne crois pas que ce soit les mêmes je
pense que jean luc mélenchon genre je ne
le crois pas vous vous dites oui mais
moi je dis non je pense que jean luc
mélenchon à dimanche soir heurter en
profondeur le
le nombre de ceux qui lui avaient fait
confiance où un grand nombre de ceux qui
essaient confiance parce que le haut
fond dans ceux qui ont apporté leur
soutien maintenant à gond il y avait
l'idée que vraiment c'était le contraire
de l'extrême droite et donc il ya eu là
quelque chose qui a été très je suis
surpris blessant pour un grand nombre de
gens mais je reviens avec la question
s'il y a un compréhension c'est qu'on ne
sait pas expliquer qu'on ne sait pas
parler qu'on ne sait pas convaincre
qu'on ne s'est pas entraîné comment
faire alors c'est quoi la stratégie cta
la question mettait toute notre énergie
et parler aux gens de leur vie arrêtons
les blablas parlons aux gens dans la
salle énergétique des discours des
manuels macra dix ans tourne beaucoup
pas du tout ce blabla soignés sous là
mais c'est vrai il a été critiqué pour
le manque d'eau ne vous plait on est
dans un discours vous avais tes mains on
est dans un moment critique où on y
écoute et moi on est dans un moment
historique
alors dans un moment historique on évite
de se laisser égarer par les par les
péripéties et on regarde l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'est que aujourd'hui la
france a un choix qui est pour la
première fois depuis des décennies
en tout cas depuis 15 ans ou 20 ans le
choix le plus clair qu'on puisse avoir
d'un côté vous avez le choix de un pays
qui veut vivre et avancer dans la
lucidité et qui accepte tous les défis
qui sont devant lui et qu'il est relève
me concrètement pratiquement et puis de
l'autre vous avez des illusions qu'ils
sont mortels
s'il n'est pas vrai qu'on va pouvoir
remettre la retraite à 60 ans il n'est
pas vrai qu'on va pouvoir augmenter le
smic de 30 % il n'est pas vrai qu'on va
pouvoir multiplier les embauches de tous
côtés il n'est pas vrai que l'argent
sera disponible et qu'on pourra tirer
des chèques sur je ne sais quelle banque
banque centrale centrale ou banque
nationale reconstituer tout est faux
dans cette affaire tout est mensonge et
de je suis sûr que le le sentiment
profond des français va le voir et donc
je refuse de me laisser égarer dans
quelques péripéties que ce soit je vais
droit au but et je dis ce qu'est le
risque et de quelle manière il faut
l'affronter
le risque qu'est ce que c'est que si
marine je n'ai été lieu la france mais
les épargnants ceux qui travaillent
aussi court à la faillite mais c'est pas
c'est pas seulement ça c'est d'abord
marine le pen ne se rappelle excusez moi
en page 1 2 milliard jeune âge je ne je
ne veux pas accréditer une telle
hypothèse je veux qu'on parte du fond et
du du plus important de l'avenir de la
vie du pays et donc le plus important de
l'avenir de la vie du pays c'est que si
on déstabilise et notre notre économie
nos finances publiques l'état
si on sortait de l'europe de l'union
européenne et de l'euro alors la france
connaîtrait le moment le plus difficile
et le plus chaotique de son histoire et
elle ne le connaîtraient pas
théoriquement au sens des idées tout ça
naturellement existent mais elles le
connaîtrai dans la vie quotidienne
spécialement la vie quotidienne de ceux
qui ont moins
vous avez parce que ce sont ceux là qui
seraient les victimes
vous avez évoqué la prise de position
enfin qui n'en est pas une pour le
restant de jean luc mélenchon de jean
luc mélenchon écouter les appels du pied
du directeur de campagne de marine le
pen
david rachline qui était sur public
sénat ce matin quand il ya des personnes
qui ont voté pour monsieur mélenchon et
qui considèrent que l'union européenne
dans sa forme actuelle prend la mauvaise
direction qui considère que lé recul des
services publics sont inacceptables qui
considère aussi que il est inacceptable
aujourd'hui de faire bénéficier du cic
et oui les grandes entreprises quand
nous nous préférons aider les petites et
les moyennes nos artisans et aux
commerçants
nous allons essayer de rassembler le
plus largement possible objectif
et évidemment d'en porter cette élection
présidentielle sur le projet que vous
connaissez les 144 engagement qui pour
un certain nombre d'entre eux sont
parfaitement compatibles
en effet avec l'ailé les inquiétudes et
les envies les désirs qui sont ceux de
certains qui se sont portés au premier
tour sur d'autres candidats dans une
prise de position publique tout à
l'heure le secrétaire national du pcf
pierre laurent a dit qu'il ne comprenait
pas ce silence insupportable de jean luc
mélenchon est ce que vous partagez cette
position bon c'est pas à moi de la
partager mais je sais une chose c'est
que des millions d'électeurs qui ont
voté pour jean luc mélenchon ne la
comprennent pas et en sont profondément
heurté alors il ya des idéologues qui
qui analyse les choses
au vu des théories et des des
propositions aussi absurdes les unes que
les autres
excusez moi de le dire pendant que nous
parlons 1 le venezuela
présenté comme un modèle a eu ces
dernières semaines 25 morts tués dans
les manifestations
parce que les produits de première
nécessité ont disparu alors on fait
comme s'il y avait des théories moi pas
moi je regarde la réalité des choses
mais donc est-ce que vous je suis sûr
qu'il ya des millions de gens ils
comprennent et pas choqué très
simplement que jean luc mélenchon n'est
pas appelé à voter contre marine le pen
à moi je suis est un shoot'em up effet
j'ai été stupéfait qu'il ne se
prononcent pas dimanche soir j'aurai
j'aurais parié à peu près de tout ce que
j'avais que ça ne serait pas le cas et
comme une évidence que disait naturel
que vous compreniez que sont blessés
tous ceux qui avaient mis leur confiance
ou en tout cas l'immense majorité de
ceux qui avaient mis leur ai dit viens
de recevoir le discours de monsieur
afghane à venir écouter avec je ne je
n'en crois rien sinon quoi rien je vois
bien les tentatives qui sont pour piper
les voies et pour essayer d'élargir
à une base électorale mais je ne crois
pas une seconde que les citoyens femmes
et hommes qui vont se prononcer dans
cette élection se laisse abuser par par
ses discours depuis le premier tour
dimanche on analyse la coexistence de
deux france une france rurale qui
rejetteraient la la mondialisation qui
serait plutôt dans une forme de réaction
par rapport à ce que nous vivons
maintenant qu'ils refuseraient l'europe
qui refuse qu'ils refuseraient le
progrès et puis une france qui serait
beaucoup plus ouverte qui est la france
des grandes villes ouvertes sur
l'extérieur sur la concurrence sur une
politique de l'offre est bien évidemment
ouverte sur l'europe
est ce que cette distinction vous la
partagez est ce qu'elle est et répond c
est ce qu il est irréductible
je ne partage pas cette analyse je ne
partage pas cette distinction
il se trouve que la france rurale je la
connais mieux que d'autres
pour ça joue fine et j'y ai grandi
j'en viens et je laime il se trouve que
la france urbaine je la connais aussi
mieux que d'autres parce que je suis à
la tête d'une ville qui a toutes ces
caractéristiques là et qui est de ce
point de vue là profondément attachante
je ne partage pas ce sentiment je pense
qu'il ya un problème c'est l'impuissance
publique qui a depuis des années
frappé de paralysie l'action publique en
france
des promesses ont été faites chaque fois
on vous annonce que l'alternance va tout
changer l'alternance entre droite et
gauche
tout cela déboucher sur un sentiment de
un ressenti de scandales de la part des
français parce qu'il voit bien que dans
leur vie rien ne change
alors bien sûr ce qu'ils ont moins de
services publics
ceux qui ont beaucoup de difficultés à
gagner leur vie je pense aux
agriculteurs je pense
aux paysans pour employer le vrai mot
tout cela en effet le ressentent plus
durement que les autres
mais sur le fond il n'est pas vrai qu'il
y ait des france aussi séparé que cela
est ce qui manque c'est des responsables
publics pour entraîner le pays pour
faire partager à l'ensemble des citoyens
l'importance des défis qu'il faut
relever pour que précisément on s'en
sortent tous ensemble dernière qu'elle
est ceci est parfaitement faisable
qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez dire d'ici
dimanche 7 mai aux électeurs de droite
hormis le simple fait de leur dire fait
barrage à l'extrême droite qu'est ce que
vous voulez qu'est-ce qu'il faut leur je
pense que la question de la france est
en jeu dans cette élection et je pense
que la grandeur de la france la dignité
de la france et l'honneur de la france
et le le lien entre français tout cela
est en jeu dans cette élection
et contrairement à ce que vous croyez
j'espère vous faire partager ce
sentiment
je ne fais pas de différence dans le
discours entre s'adresser à une partie
de l'électorat qu'on appelle de droite
s'adressait à une partie de l'électorat
qu'on appelle de gauche
je pense que tout cela sont des citoyens
français et que tout cela on dans les
douze jours qui viennent maintenant à
mesurer l'importance de leur choix c'est
cette importance là qui moi me mobilise
et qui me et qui me pousse en élevé à la
passion de sept engagés emmanuel macron
s'il est élu contrairement à jacques
chirac en 2002 il aura entendu elle
appelle le soutien des électeurs venus
de tout l'échiquier je suis persuadé est
persuadé je suis persuadé que oui et
d'ailleurs la démarche politique qu'il a
choisie qui ressemble en effet la
démarche politique que j'ai toujours
essayé de défendre c'est précisément de
ne pas faire de séparation dans ceux qui
ont envie de le suivre ou de lait d
entre eux les camps l'effraction et les
parties alors on va voir justement
comment
président que vous souteniez qui sera
peut-être et luxueux certainement élus
vous en avez la certitude vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure je ne pourrai jamais
employé au vernet sertic à vous dont il
sera et moi j'avais sa sélection a battu
une histoire à et je j'ai une chance à
ces way assez rare rêver d un c'est que
j'ai participé à plusieurs élections
présidentielles et je n'ai jamais dans
ces élections pensé que c'était joué à
dakar en s'accordant que c'était facile
va bien alors le pense pas cela
merci jean francis et donc c'est jérémy
marot de la sp qui nous rejoint
maintenant l'épreuve de vérité
bonsoir amis sur michel bonsoir monsieur
bayrou alors vous refusé d'imaginer
l'hypothèse d'une marine le pen qui
accède au pouvoir le 7 mai on se rejette
le 7 mai au soir emmanuel macron est élu
avec qui il gouverne avec quelle
majorité qui gouverne avec la majorité
que lui donneront les français que lui
ont donné les lui auront donné les
français s'il est élu parce que s'il est
élu c'est que précisément la majorité
des français aura choisi de lui apporté
son suffrage et son soutien ça constitue
une majorité à partir de cette majorité
présidentielle
il va former une majorité législative et
je n'ai pour ma part aucun doute que
comme ils l'ont fait à chaque élection
sans exception les français l'ayant élu
président de la république lui donnerons
les moyens de gouverner et les parties
comment dirais-je qui ne sont pas au
deuxième tour qui ont été écartés par
les citoyens c'est parti là qui essaye
d'expliquer que par l'élection
législative on pourra empêcher le
président de la république de gouverner
se trompent
pour vous les vrais ans et ne lui le
risque de les valider ne le suivront pas
la cohabitation je considère enfin moi
je suis je crois de toutes mes fibres
que les français seront cohérent seront
simplement tireront les conséquences des
choix qu'ils ont fait en donnant au
président de la république élu la
majorité qui lui permettrait de
gouverner et ça aura un autre avantage
c'est que cette majorité permettra de
renouveler profondément les visages de
la vie politique française alors d'ores
et déjà il faut préparer aussi les
élections
cela ti vct on attend toujours d
investiture pour l'instant seulement 14
tant mieux tant mieux mais je veux dire
le l'idée qu'on peut lui ré ou qu'on
troublerait ou qu'on ne pèserait sur
l'élection présidentielle par la
distribution d'investiture pour des
élections législatives qui vont venir
plusieurs semaines après est une idée
baroque
en tout cas moi je considère que c'est
une idée qui qui n'est pas cohérente
tout le monde sait que quand il ya des
investitures ça provoque des sentiments
mitigés chez les uns et chez les autres
chez tous ceux qui pensent ou
souhaiteraient avoir ces investitures
c'est donc pas le moment
en plaine entre les deux tours d'une
élection présidentielle d'annoncer des
investitures aux législatives
en tout cas telle est mon sentiment
pourtant emmanuel macron l'annoncé l'a
dit à plusieurs reprises il y aura une
vague d'investiture entre les deux tours
s'était dit encore la semaine dernière
un jeu en attendant peut-être l'at-il
dit mais si j'ai un conseil
elle rappelle pas si j'ai un conseil à
exprimer c'est que il faut se concentrer
sur l'élection présidentielle faut se
concentrer sur la question qui est posée
aux français pour une fois dans une
absolue transparence que que voulez-vous
que soit l'avenir de notre pays vous
avez deux propositions politiques qui
sont en effet deux propositions
politiques qui ne qui ne disent pas la
même chose de la france et de l'avenir
de la france et je n'ai pas de doute que
les français vont se prononcer de
manière absolument clair qu'ils vont
répondre à cette question et tous les
tous les moments de d'authenticité pour
le pays permettent de répondre à cette
question qui est une question de devis
des citoyens alors nous avons envie de
former un pays rassembler et pas un pays
divisé
nous avons envie de nous respecter et
pas de nous mépriser
nous avons envie tiens j'étais ce matin
peut-être vous aussi l'avez-vous suivi
aux obsèques du policier du jeune
policier qui a et nous l'avons suivie
vers ont tous été bouleversés par rien
entendu j'ai été moi bouleversé par le
discours du compagnon de du jeune
policier tué c'était un discours
magnifique de di tu es magnifique de
justesse magnifique de générosité et ce
discours était du côté d'un pays qui se
rassemblent et pas d'un pays qui qui qui
fait prospérer des divisions et des
ressentiments et pourtant dieu sait que
quand on perd un être cher dans des
circonstances comme celles là il ya
toutes les raisons d'être habité par
cette et bien non c'est de donner ce
jeune homme a un superbe exemple
en tout cas je l'ait entendu comme tel
et tout le monde était bouleversé
quelles que soient les opinions
vous avez vous gardé des larmes dans les
yeux de tous ceux qui étaient là et je
vous jure qu'à cet instant il n'y avait
aucune aucune idée de ou aucune volonté
d'aller vers ce pays en affrontement où
on voudrait nous entraîner reste il ya
le débat politique et donc vous êtes sûr
qu'il y aura une majorité cohérente pour
emmanuel marolle course il était l'une
écoutons quand même ce que dit par
exemple bruno le maire lui il imagine
quand même
les potées aucune majorité claire se
dégage et et il est prêt à une alliance
on écoute s'il n'y a pas de majorité
claire se voudra dire quoi se dire que
les français nous ont dit travailler
ensemble débrouillez-vous ce cas là je
ne me déroberai pas à mes responsables à
dire que vous pourriez travailler avec
emmanuel macron évidemment je pourrais
travailler avec le prochain président
république si celui-ci ses genoux
réserve que les français ne décide
oui dans la clarté oui c'est à dire avec
une situation politique clarifier au
lendemain des élections législatives au
10 juin oui alors la main est temps de
vous l'avez vous voyez vous voyez que
tout le monde y vient
vous aviez entendu les débats des
primaires les les anathèmes les
condamnations
et puis vous voyez que devant
l'événement devant la gravité de la
situation
tout le monde à droite et à gauche et au
centre dit mais au fond c'est ce qu'il
faut faire il faudra travailler ensemble
on ne pourra pas faire autrement que de
travailler ensemble et donc vous voyez
que tout ce qu'ils proposeraient aux
français de délire une majorité de
paralysie de l'action du nouveau
président de la république tout cela son
rang rejeté cette c'est un peuple qui a
une grande habitude de cette cohérence
au travers du temps je me souviens de
françois mitterrand qui disait en 1981
deux j'étais très jeune citoyen il
visait en 1981 vous n'imaginez tout de
même pas que les français seront assez
stupide pour mes lire président mais me
refuser une majorité en juin et ceux ci
c'est un argument de bon sens et de
responsabilité et les deux auront leur
rôle
parlant de la droite justement pour
l'instant un seul parlementaire a
rejoint en marche c'est le sénateur jean
baptiste lemoyne la droite reste pour
l'instant groupe et comment ne pas rater
l'ouverture vers la droite et convaincre
ces parlementaires de vous rejoindre et
de gouverner alors quand vous dites que
ce ce parti reste groupé c'est que vous
ne lisez pas les articles que vous
écrivez officiellement il ya une
position commune maintenant il ya des
individualités qui s'exprime par exemple
alain juppé alain juppé dit qu'il faut
en or et réorienter la politique de son
parti donc vers une politique humaniste
européenne et là vous vous soyez à
peut-être parfait trait d'union ont vu
votre proximité avec la lgp en
traversant les couloirs du sénat pour
venir à votre émission j'ai rencontré
plusieurs parlementaires de de l air de
l'ump devenu l air et tous disent aimer
c'est pas possible connaît une position
comme ça faut qu'on dise des choses
claires alors je ne dis pas que c'est
l'unanimité puisqu'il paraît qu'ils se
sont divisés je dis que c'est le
sentiment de responsabilité qui
qu'éprouve un grand nombre de ceux qui
sont les cadres et les animateurs de ce
mouvement et il me semble que dans les
heures qui viennent ou dans les jours
qui viennent a beaucoup de ceux là vont
s'exprimer avec un appel beaucoup de
ceux là vont s'exprimer pour dire
clairement vers qui va leur choix et que
nul ne puisse mettre en cause les
orientations qu'ils vont exprimer ce
bayrou veut s'attacher à la transparence
données notées et vous donne des jeux je
ne suis pas la seule science trop si je
ne sois pas là vous voyez vous
connaissez beaucoup donné à la jupe
légation vos contacts avec lui en ce
moment je veux dire quoi ça va des bras
et je ne me sens pas autorisés à faire
des déclarations à la place de ceux qui
en sont les responsables sauf que vous
vous avez des contacts directs avec
alain juppé je reviens sur ce sujet et
donc chacun s'exprimera et je ne doute
pas de la force de leur expression
pouvez vous nous dresser le profil idéal
pour un gouvernement d'ouverture des
milliers de droite des milieux gauches
dès 1910 je n'ai aucune envie de jouer à
ce jeu je vous demande pardon parce que
c'est un jeu qui vous plairait beaucoup
et peut-être monsieur vous avez beaucoup
de choses à dire sur les jeunes grenier
vous retenez la wii jeu j'ai beaucoup de
choses à penser sur le sujet
écrit des centaines de pages pour
expliquer ce que je croyais ce que je
crois c'est que la grande majorité des
français partagent les mêmes valeurs et
les mêmes orientations pour l'avenir
ce que je crois c'est que la grande
majorité des français par exemple est
attaché à l'idéal européen
la grande majorité est agacé par la
manière dont l'europe fonctionne ou
plutôt ne fonctionne pas à la manière
dont le les les mécaniques de décisions
européennes sont pas assez efficaces et
dissimulé ou en tout cas opaque aux yeux
des citoyens et je partage la
satisfaction et je partage l'idéal et je
suis sûr qu autour de cela il y a une
grande majorité de français
vous croyez que les français ne voient
pas que dans le monde dangereux où nous
sommes ceux qui leur proposent de
s'isoler les conduisent à la catastrophe
vous croyez que que quand ils pensent à
leurs enfants ignorent ça mais il ment
solidaires qu'on n'a pas suffisamment
pris en compte la présence du front
national au second tour il a déclaré
aujourd'hui 20 1 françois hollande bon
on est dans une situation de transition
et mais il s'est exprimé clairement le
problème c'est que il n'aurait pas fallu
laisser grandir les raisons qui ont fait
le succès du front national et ceci jeu
limpide pas françois hollande uniquement
jeu l'imputent à une longue période dans
laquelle le la la pratique politique n'a
pas donné les résultats que les citoyens
étaient en droit d'attendre une dernière
question permettez moi juste d'un
système et dans les principes forts
pouvait assister ça m'étonnerait que
votre ingérence et raison de mes
résistance en les principes forts qui
ont été édictées par emmanuel macron il
ya celui du pluralisme du renouvellement
on parle par exemple pour les
législatives de 50 % de candidats issus
laisser au moins deux villes au moins et
50 % au plus donc
d'élus qui sont ces élus est ce que ce
sont des élus de droite de gauche du
centre on y voit pas très clair pour
l'instant c'est que beaucoup de rallier
donc je peux et je peins je peux vous
dire une chose certaine c'est que le
mouvement démocrate que je préside sera
en tant que tel présent dans cette
majorité nouvellement vous avez un
accord et nous avons un accord nous
avons une alliance et que je peux vous
dire aussi une chose c'est que les
candidats qui seront présentés
n'appartiendront pas au monde des
sortants parce que nous n'avons pas de
sortant à nantes avant de nécessiter son
seront évidemment dans cette série et
donc oui pour moi c'est cet engagement
de renouvellement et cet engagement de
pluralisme
c'est ce qui a fait le saut même de
notre alliance toute dernière question
hier cet accord cette alliance que vous
évoquez c'est un peu secret défense un
canton demande combien de
circonscriptions réservées aux élus mais
bien comme ça quand on vous posera la
question vous direz que vous ne savez
pas c'est le but de va là on remercie
jérémy et mickaël szames est tout de
suite nous rejoint pour la dernière
partie de l'épreuve de vérité
[Musique]
bonsoir michaëlle jean michel nous
sommes monsieur bayrou bonsoir emmanuel
macron ne crois pas aux 100 premiers
jours d'un président at il tort je
comprends très bien ce qui dit quand il
dit que ce n'est pas son approche des
choses mais il ya beaucoup de choses
qu'il faut faire dans les 100 premiers
jours et des engagements qu'il a pris
il y en a par exemple c'est que avant
l'élection les élections législatives
il nous poserons il posera sur la table
du conseil des ministres
une loi de moralisation de la vie
publique c'est dur à ce que je dis pas
que ce soit d'urgence jeudi que ça on
peut le faire en quelques jours
on peut écrire cette loi avec les
différents aspects qui doivent être les
siens par exemple une guerre sans pitié
contre les conflits d'intérêts où les
soupçons de conflit d'intérêts est ce
qu'on appelle conflit d'intérêts c'est
très simple c'est quand l'intérêt privé
l'emportent sur l'intérêt général que
ont fait en sorte que la décision
publique
elles soient prises pour au bénéfice
d'intérêts privés à 14h06 un homme
politique d'avoir un autre métier comme
avocat interdire à un homme politique
d'être le conseil comme on dit entre
guillemets de deux des sociétés qui
pourraient avoir intérêt à ses choix et
donc ceci se fait dans tous les autres
pays démocratiques d'europe en tout cas
deuxièmement il faut avoir une certitude
que le financement de la politique
devient clair par exemple la politique
est pleine de micro partis comme vous
savez plusieurs centaines qu'est ce que
c'est les micro partis cette la manière
légale de tourner la loi c'est à dire
chacun organise sa petite boutique avec
son propre financement qui échappe à la
loi sur le financement des partis
je considère que ça ne va pas et ainsi
de suite il ya un certain nombre de
châteaux moralisation de la vigne
lyc est ce que emmanuel macron a dit
c'est que ce serait sur la table du
conseil des ministres avant les
élections le premier déplacement que
ferait le président s'il gagne emmanuel
macron est-ce qu'il doit la corde et
angela merkel
oui j'imagine qu'il pense pas autrement
alors que la merkel à son gouvernement à
ceux qui ont la charge de diriger le
pays qui est notre premier partenaire
notre premier client notre premier
fournisseur et notre premier ami il ya
eu aujourd'hui une mode de la
détestation de l'allemagne moi je pense
que cette mode est néfaste pour la
france parce qu'elle nous et empêche de
voir en face les problèmes qui se posent
à nos deux peuples aux nôtres et à nos
deux peuples ensemble de réconciliation
du couple franco allemand c'est ce que
vos voisins allemands de réconciliation
de de nouvelles impulsions voilà d'un
nouvel élan de deux peuples qui décide
d'affronter ensemble parce qu'ils sont
voisins les réalités du monde et ainsi
de donner à l'europe
cette nouvelle impulsion qui permettra
de répondre à la critique que les
citoyens et met sur le fonctionnement de
l'union recevoir avant le premier tour
avec l'attentât qui a eu lieu à paris on
a beaucoup entendu parler des candidats
qui militait pour une urgence et la
priorité soit mise sur les actions
contre le terrorisme oui que du coup
cette priorité là ne devrait pas passer
avant la loi de moralisation tous les
mois enfin la mobilisation des services
de renseignement et des services de
police elle est entière et vous ne
pouvez pas insinuer le contraire au
moment où nous venons sans les autres
candidats qui longtemps glaner ce qu'il
insinue ne vont pas dans le bon sens y
est même des candidats qui proposait de
désarmer le les policiers un ou deux
désarmé notre pays moi en tout cas ça
n'est pas mon sentiment
mon sentiment est que la mobilisation
n'est pas une question de quelques
semaines c'est une question de tous les
jours pendant les cinq années que nous
allons vivre et j'ai exprimé vous m'avez
souvent entendu le dire l'idée que le
suivi de la menace l'observation fine de
la manière dont évoluent les choses de
la part des terroristes doit être notre
guide
c'est nous avons constamment adapter la
défense à la menace
la menace évolue la défense doit évoluer
aussi voilà pourquoi emmanuel macron
propose de réorganiser donc devancé le
renseignement
mais ce sera une oeuvre de cinq années
là vous m'interrogez sur les progrès
limités
ah ben il y aurait alors du mal au début
il y aura les dossiers économiques et
sociaux et emmanuel macron a annoncé au
doute
une nouvelle loi travail il n'a exprimé
d'ailleurs sur public sénat on écoute
une réforme par ordonnance je propose
qu'une concertation accéléré en début de
quinquennat et sur ce sujet là qu'on
fonctionne par ordonnance pour le faire
durant l'été pourquoi parce qu'il a
besoin d'un choc de confiance d'une
vraie accélération d'une détermination à
l'épreuve et parce que nous avons besoin
de faire passer cette réforme pour que
les premiers effets s'en fassent sentir
assez rapidement vous confirmez ce qui
est concertation qu'en face les sharks
de genre et choc de confiance et ces
deux mots sont deux mots clés avec le
risque de on a vu ce que ça a donné avec
la loi elle conneries non mais comment
faire l'élection présidentielle va
intervenir l'élection présidentielle
donne au président un mandat l'élection
législative et élections législatives
vont suivre elle donne à la majorité et
au gouvernement un mandat est de ce
point de vue là oui la légitimité plus
forte que celle des gouvernements
précédents qui avaient qui d'une
certaine manière faisait un peu le
contraire de ce qu'ils avaient dit qu'il
ferait comprenez c'est pas la même chose
d'agir lorsque vous avez un mandat
d'agir en dehors de tout mandat
et le et le travail qui lie à faire je
vous rappelle que les ordonnances
elles sont votées à l'assemblée de
rentabilité c'est maintenant c'est
quelque chose qui vient d'infliger une
phrase il ya des sujets sur lesquels on
doit on peut on doit avancer par
ordonnance pour éviter l'enlisement dans
lequel on vit depuis trop longtemps
l'enlisement ça ressemble aussi à ce
qu'on avait entendu par exemple le 49-3
ça se ressemble un petit peu ou pas
c'est pas exactement mon sentiment
moi je pense que le 49-3 a été choquant
parce que le débat n'a pas eu lieu
donc avec des ordonnances le débat aura
lieu donc il ya un débat sur la loi
d'habilitation par ordonnance le
gouvernement vient devant le parlement
et il dit au parlement qu elles vont
être ses orientations et ses choix et le
parlement lui donne cette cette
habilitation
est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre dans
l'antre de tours vous avez certainement
dû en parler avec emmanuel macron a
peut-être une mesure sorti du chapeau
concernant les syndicats je déteste le
mot sorti du chapeau
je n'ai pas c'est pas de la
prestidigitation le train qui n'a pas
encore été annoncée à grove a préféré va
avoir à en effet expliciter les choix
qui sont les siens certains qu'il a déjà
annoncé qu'ils n'ont pas été entendus
parce que le brouhaha de la campagne
électorale empêcher qu'ils fussent
tentant but et peut-être d'autres qu'il
exprimera pourra ressembler à quoi
notamment une plus forte présence dans
les conseils d'administration je ne sais
pas si vous avez compris mais je ne suis
pas le candidat à la présidence de la
république peut-être il se
n'accompagnerait pas nous dire vous
savez ce qu on pourrait conseiller donc
oui en tout cas je parle avec lui je
suis pas je suis pas dans une fonction
de conseiller
il ya une nouvelle loi sur le marché du
travail notamment red hot à moteur
renforcement des relations et kristen
cas vous ne risquez pas n'est pas
crainte d'avoir une rentrée sociale
importante avec des gens dans la rue et
notamment ceux qui ont voté pour une
personne jean luc mélenchon qui était
plutôt dans la contestation et bien je
ne le crois pas vous parlez de la
légitimité mais pour cela il faudrait qu
emmanuel macron obtiennent quel
pourcentage
de voir ça sera pas les 80 % de chirac
n'attendez pas de rouiba les 90 ans de
jacques chirac n'ont pas donné la
légitimité qu'il aurait fallu
précisément parce que jacques chirac a
choisi à l'époque il a écrit depuis
qu'il le regrettait a choisi à l'époque
de au fond de ne pas tenir compte de de
l'importance de la base de ce qu'ils lui
avaient apporté leur confiance
mais manuel mac on ne veut pas d'un
nouveau projet de loi de finances
rectificatif
et c'est à dire que le dernier budget du
quinquennat de françois hollande est le
bon l'idée que emmanuel macron développe
c'est que en matière de finances
publiques il faut respecter ses
engagements
il ya beaucoup de gens qui rêvait ou
proposés dans cette élection de ne plus
respecter les engagements
moi j'apprécie que à qu'on dise nous
allons respecter les engagements de la
france
j'ai une petite dernière question plus
personnelle si vous le permettez maire
de pau vous êtes vous resterai après le
7 mai eh bien nous verrons ensemble
comment je peux répondre à deux
impératifs que je vais rappeler devant
vous le premier c'est que je suis
attachée à ma ville et que je resterai
dans cet attachement et que je ferai
tout ce que je peux pour qu'elle se
développe
ancien maire et le deuxième je ferai
tout ce que je peux pour que mon pays ce
tir se sortent de la crise dans laquelle
il est
vous voyez que ce sont deux engagements
qui sont condamnant très complémentaires
je vais vous dire pourquoi parce que y'a
le cumul des mandats un citoyen de pau
il a deux appartenances y les citoyens
de cette ville formidable et en même
temps il est citoyen français et sa vie
elle dépend du développement de la ville
et du redressement du pays
donc vous serez dans deux endroits
banques sauvées
tout ce que je pourrai pour remplir ces
deux engagements avec quand même temps
qu en même temps et en heure et en même
temps de responsabilité une d'élus
une au service de l'exécutif eh bien
nous verrons nous verrons verrons si
c'est uniquement le président de la
république et lui qui peut décider de ce
genre de jouer en toute confidence vous
allez nous dire qu'on n'en avait pas
parlé encore avec lui je n'ai jamais à
notre dernière question vous avez eu
d'éclats de rires non mais je n'en je
voudrais vous dire une chose et moi très
simple je vous crois il ya des gens qui
racontent des histoires à et moi je vais
force de dire la vérité
c'est surprenant sur ce plateau et
americana tous les gens que vous invitez
vous raconte nicolas sarkozy variantes
de nicolas mas en tout cas quand je vous
dis que je n'en ai pas parlé avec lui
c'est que je n'en ai pas la sarkozy va
annoncer qu'ils votent macron sais ce
que c'est ce qu'annonce la fp vous vous
saluer ou le statut et la peau dure le
le choix responsable c'est celui qu'on
annonce truire la sarkozie ekoué que
vont prononcer un grand nombre d'autres
responsables du parti des républicains
je n'ai aucun doute qu'ils vont tous
s'extraire de le 2 de cette ambiguïté
pour prononcer le choix civique que la
france attend merci à vous on va
continuer à suivre cette campagne sur
public sénat et demain d'ailleurs il y
aura une nouvelle épreuve de vérité avec
payant philippot le numéro 2 du front
national bonsoir à demain
[Musique]